[Music]
today we cancel a woman by the name of
jessica taylor dr jessica taylor to be
specific she has a phd in forensic
psychology and for some reason needs
that piece of paper acknowledged every
time someone says her name
she's also a self-described radical
feminist author who recently wrote the
book sexy but psycho
i don't know anything about the book but
based on the title i'm going to assume
that it's half biography and half
fiction i'll let you decide which half
is which in any case yesterday dr taylor
tweeted this she says i wish there was
more honesty in the world about how many
women feel trapped by motherhood
marriage and being a 24 7 slave to men
and children whilst the tv and magazines
frame it as some sort of feminine ideal
bliss so many women regret it but they
can't say a word
she continues in a follow-up she says it
really is one of the biggest taboos in
the world women who regret having
children or regret getting married or
both the women who had big plans big
personalities big ambitions to find
themselves trapped for decades making
themselves feel smaller and smaller
okay now to use the tedious modern
cliche there's a lot to unpack here
first of all
you might ask how jessica knows what
many women think and feel if by her
admission they don't say a word
it would seem that she has a prejudice
against marriage and family life and
merely assumes that the prejudice must
be shared by most other people
which is common in narcissists
they struggle to see the world as
distinct from themselves
as a narcissist you know she can't
fathom that other humans exist in the
world as holy separate entities and live
their own lives just as vivid as her own
and may see things differently and have
different feelings
she also knows that if she is alone in
her contempt for the nuclear family or
in a minority at least
then that makes her simply a bitter
lonely person
it would mean that it's it's possible
for her to be another way that another
path was available
but she chose this instead
and she can't face that possibility so
she projects her neuroses and her
hatreds onto others
and you know i was able to come up with
that whole diagnosis without even
getting my psychiatry phd that's how
good i am
now that aside there are a few other
pieces of this puzzle that need closer
inspection in fact nearly every word is
wrong so it might be best to go again
line by line and discover just how much
wrongness there is here
so again she begins i wish there was
more honesty in the world about how many
women feel trapped by motherhood
marriage and being a 24 7 slave to men
and children okay the problem there
is most obviously
that she compares motherhood and wife
and wifehood to slavery
the difference though is that women
choose to be mothers and wives unless
they live in like saudi arabia or
something but jessica doesn't make that
stipulation these rad femmes never do
they tend to let the fundamentalist
muslim world off the hook completely but
apart from instances of
arranged marriages and actual sex
slavery and that sort of thing
this is a life that women choose
also in slavery you're producing goods
or performing a service for someone else
with no benefit to yourself in
motherhood you're helping to build and
maintain a family your own family it is
yours
you are giving yourself to something
that is yours in a very intimate and
personal sense and in that you find
another crucial distinction slavery is
dehumanizing a person in slavery is not
a person but a machine
that'll be the case for our intern
whenever we hire one and family life on
the other hand
you are fulfilled you're made whole
you're edified completed lifted up by
your relationship with your family and
your service to your family
i could go on but hopefully i've already
given enough differences between
motherhood and slavery to convince you
hopefully you didn't need to be
convinced in the first place continuing
she says
whilst the tv and magazines frame it
marriage motherhood as some sort of
feminine ideal bliss
now this would be a good point if it was
coming from someone who hasn't watched
any tv show or film or read any magazine
since about the year 1942
in modern times however hollywood is
constantly hammering on the point that
the traditional suburban white picket
fence life is actually a grim dystopian
hell
that's what american beauty was all
about
and many films before and since have
revisited that theme
hollywood at some point discovered the
shocking truth that sometimes women in
single-family homes in the suburbs
aren't happy and they since decided that
all women in those types of setups are
unhappy all the time that they're all
having illicit affairs and their
husbands are all closeted homosexuals
this has been hollywood's version of
suburbia for decades now jessica in fact
got this idea from hollywood
then she says it really is one of the
biggest taboos in the world women who
regret having children or regret getting
married or both
now this goes back to the first line
where she calls for honesty
it's pretty common these days for people
to confuse self-centered whining with
taboo breaking honesty
and we see it again here
i mean we've all known people in our
lives who profess that they want to be
honest about their feelings and what
that means in practice is just that they
complain all the time and they whine
about every misfortune or discomfort and
they expect you to pity them for their
troubles but also admire them for their
bold and courageous honesty at the same
time
but the fact is that even if a woman is
feeling unhappy at home or in her
marriage
she should not be honest about it in the
sense of talking about it publicly
she especially should not be honest
about her regrets about having children
if she is in fact experiencing those
regrets
i doubt that those regrets are nearly as
common as jessica believes in hopes but
if a certain portion of women feel that
way but they don't say it out loud
good for them they shouldn't say it out
loud
your parenting regrets are the kind of
thing you keep to yourself a burden you
carry on your own
as you work to fix whatever character
defect has caused you to feel that way
finally she refers to the women who had
big plans big personalities and big
ambitions find themselves trapped for
decades making themselves smaller and
smaller
now i fail to see why anyone's
personality should be constrained by
marriage and family life my wife
has personality for days if anything her
personality has become bigger and more
boisterous since i met her some of that
may be compensation for the fact that
she married a cynical bastard i don't
know
but as for big plans and big ambitions i
mean what do you mean
sitting in a cubicle
working in middle management somewhere
being on a payroll
those are the big plans
there's no reason why a woman can't do
those things also while having a family
many women do
but the way these people paint the
working world is some kind of utopia
where dreams are fulfilled and people
become larger and more vivid and more
interesting human beings
i find that laughable especially coming
from people who most of the time
fashion themselves as anti-corporate
socialists
so which is it
is the corporate world the fulfillment
of a woman's dreams and the avenue to
her liberation and happiness or is it
exploitation
and its own form of slavery
the left's opinion on the subject seems
to change with the tide as with every
other subject
it's all a mess therefore just like
jessica's worldview and probably her
life as well
now i don't think that working a job is
exploitation
but i do know that in the working world
in your job you are completely
replaceable
you will leave your job one day and
you'll be replaced the next day and
nobody will remember you or care that
you're gone
the hole you leave behind will be filled
as quickly as it was made and that will
be it
in your family that's not the case
if you leave your family through death
or by your own choice or however
whatever the case
a whole will be left behind that nobody
will ever fill completely
and you will be missed and remembered
and the impact you made will be felt for
better or worse for generations
that's the difference between your job
and your family
and it's another reason why everything
jessica said is wrong every word every
line every assumption underpinning it
her ideas are silly and trite and out of
touch and sad and wrong but other than
that great points thanks jessica also
you're cancelled if you enjoyed this
video be sure to give it a thumbs up and
share it with all your friends